Britney Spears has a book coming out and
um you know everything going on in the
world this is the good news at least
that all of the most insufferable women
in the country uh apparently have
Memoirs coming out we have Jada pinkin
Smith as a memoir Britney Spears as a
memoir now we just need one from I don't
know Joy bear and uh we'll really
complete the trifecta but there's one
Revelation from the book that's getting
a lot of attention and uh here's MBC
news
listen we're back now with a major
Revelation from pop icon Britney Spears
an excerpt from her new book called The
Woman in me provided to People magazine
Spears said she had an abortion as a
teenager after a pregnancy with Justin
Timberlake for more on this let's bring
in Ken Rosen blat she's NBC news's Youth
and internet culture reporter great to
have you with us good morning Ken so
this abortion bombshell is really what
everybody is talking about so far in
what we've seen from the book what
exactly does she say happen and how does
she feel about it
now good morning Savannah and Joe so
Britney Spears talks about being being
deeply in love with Justin Timberlake at
the time and although they weren't
really ready for this she said she'd
always anticipated starting a family
with him and that they were going to
share their Futures together so when he
said that he wasn't ready to be a father
she said it was a really difficult
decision for her she said she has since
agonized over this decision and that
it's been a really big challenge for her
and and fans are really empathizing with
what she says in this book about being
really conflicted about having this
abortion after falling pregnant in her
either early teens or or sorry her late
teames or her early
20s and has Justin Timberlake responded
at all to the book or to this
claim People magazine had reached out to
Justin Timberlake but no reps have
responded yet for him all right so the
free Britney movement of course was a
huge part of her being released from her
conservatorship how are they reacting to
this
Revelation yeah so fans online are
really heartbroken for Britney they say
you know Justin Timberlake has in the
past been under scrutiny for some of his
uh treatment around Britney Spears or
how some of that relationship shook out
so now fans are really reassessing some
of the music from that time they're
saying they're really heartbroken over
the song um All right so this is good
news the free Britney movement is on the
case and that makes me feel much better
you know the idiots who demanded that a
mentally unstable woman be freed from
her conservatorship because they saw a
documentary about it and assumed that
yeah they saw a documentary and that was
enough for them to sum up like years and
years and years of court cases and
everything else and they knew everything
they needed to know based on that that
we need to free
Britney and now they're chiming in which
is which is fantastic this is an
interesting story though and it's a sad
one apparently Britney Spears at some
point as a young adult you know maybe 19
or
20 is the Assumption had an abortion at
she says Justin Timberlake's
insistance
now a few things here number one Britney
Spears was we must say a
multi-millionaire at the time so the
idea that she had to kill her baby
because she couldn't care for the child
without Timberlake's help uh just
doesn't fly she was a very wealthy woman
who had an abortion rather than care for
a
child and uh that's what happened and
she's responsible for her own choices
trying to pawn this all off on the guy
or acting like she was a destitute
desperate poor woman with no other
choice or whatever all of that is wrong
not that an abortion would be justified
if she was poor but but she wasn't so
that's the F thing now now that said if
the story is true then Justin Timberlake
carries an equal amount of the blame as
it was equally his child and they're
both
responsible uh which needs to be
said uh but there's there's this thing
that happens in in the pro-life
movement where pro-lifers don't want to
be seen as villainizing women and they
especially uh and and they want to be
able to reach women especially before an
abortion happen happens be able to reach
out to them this is what this is what uh
Pregnancy Resource Centers are all about
which is good like you want to be able
to reach with especially when you're
dealing with a woman who uh is
contemplating abortion but hasn't gone
through with it yet then the approach is
certainly not to shout at them and
scream at them and Heap guilt and all of
that because if you do that then it's
just just going to send them into the
arm that's what the abortion industry
wants you to do because it sends them in
and it sends the woman into their uh
demonic
arms and Pregnancy Resource Centers and
you got sidewalk counselors that go to
the abortion clinics they know all of
this and they're very good at reaching
out to these women um and not not not
sugar coating what the issue at all um
but at the same time reaching out in
love with grace and patience and all
that and that that's all
good but there it there's a segment of
the pro-life movement that that goes too
far in wanting to to completely absolve
the women entirely of any guilt
whatsoever and and to paint and to to
present it as though the women are just
as much victims of abortion as the child
as if they have no
agency and I I'm seeing this
um and it's true that that it is true
that oftentimes women are are exploited
by the abortion industry are lied to and
we should keep that in mind um as well
but I'm I'm just seeing that with this
story as well I'm seeing some Pro lifers
that are well this is all about Justin
timberl he's the villain here let's talk
about him let's not well no hang on a
second she she might she she was a 19 or
20-y old woman Filthy
Rich and uh decided Well if Timberlake
isn't on board then I'm going to kill
the child I mean that that to absolve
her of of guilt is not the right
approach
either I mean the answer is that this is
it
a every baby has a mother and a father
and if both the mother and father are on
board with killing the child then
they're both as far as I'm concerned
equally to
blame um but what I really want to focus
on is is is the sadness the Heartbreak
that we're hearing
about uh Britney Spear says she's still
torn up about it the media is reporting
this as sad news heartbreaking news we
just heard that that people are
heartbroken fans are
heartbroken and it is very sad and it is
heartbreaking anytime a child is killed
it is sad and
heartbreaking um I I don't have any any
problem with people taking that tone
when talking about abortion that's the
appropriate tone it's a terrible thing
but it's interesting that people who
support abortion people who defend a
woman's quote unquote right to abortion
will describe it this way you know we
talked about this recently it's and it's
something that the pro-abortion if
you're on the pro abortion side you
should really think about that and I
know that there are in fact uh
plenty of people on the prob bortion
side who watch this show because I hear
from them so if you're in that camp ask
yourself this if abortion is not the
killing of a human child then why is it
sad why is it such a mournful difficult
subject the October 15th tax deadline
has just passed I know many of you might
be dreading the stress of filing your
taxes filing your taxes can be a long
excruciating process but if you fail to
file you'll start to uh pile up penel
ities on your tax debt that's why you
need to check out tax Network USA the
team at tax Network USA has a track
record of success they have reduced tax
debt for numerous clients totaling over
$1 billion whether you're looking at a
$10,000 a $1 million tax debt they can
help you with a settlement it doesn't
matter if you haven't filed in one year
five years even a Whole Decade tax
Network USA is equipped to secure the
best settlement for you the experts
attorneys and tax professionals of tax
Network USA can help resolve all tax
cases no no matter how they started
don't let tax debt control your life any
longer take the first step toward
resolving your tax issues by visiting
tax Network
usa.com Walsh that's tax Network usa.com
Walsh
today I mean either way um no it's
either is it's a either or okay this is
a it's a binary choice either abortion
kills a human person or it doesn't and
if it
doesn't which is what you
claim then there's nothing sad about it
if the quote unquote fetus is a lifeless
inhuman clump of cells with no value
then an abortion is no different from
getting like a wart removed and why
would anyone talk about a wart removal
like it's some tragic thing why would a
woman still be mourning the loss of a
wart 20 years later it's
absurd
so if you see this kind of story as sad
then you must realize at some level that
the child is not a warted
that the child is not some lifeless
growth but is indeed a
child and if you recognize that
intuitively then how can you support
abortion at all I mean how can you
defend the killing of of a human
child okay the only thing that could
ever make abortion defensible is if it
is not the killing of a human
child that's the only thing can make a
defensible but
um and even then I I wouldn't say that
it's that it's defensible I've talked
about this before you know the claim
that it's not a child but merely a
potential child well abortion still is
not justified even if what we're dealing
with is the
potential
but that's the only way you can even get
halfway to to making an argument in
support of abortion is first you have to
uh make the case success successfully
that the child is not is is not a human
child which you can't make that case
because it's
ridiculous
um but if the child is a human child
then then killing a human child is wrong
self-evidently it's like it it's the
definition of an evil act it's the kind
of thing where if that's not
wrong then I don't know what the word
wrong means
anymore if it's not wrong to
intentionally deliberately kill an
innocent human child then what what
could possibly qualify as
wrong you you've taken the worst kind of
thing and you have um excused it and so
in so doing you have excused everything
else down the line before you get to the
worst
thing so that is really the Dilemma
um and the only consistent position if
you're if you're Pro
abortion
uh you you have to see abortion as like
a happy or at least neutral thing but I
think most people even if they claim to
be Pro abortion they intuitively
recognize that it is sad it is
heartbreaking and if your mind is
telling you that that it's sad and
heartbreaking you should really ask
yourself why thanks for checking out
this video if you'd like to listen to my
full podcast on the go you can check out
the Matt wall show on Apple podcast
Spotify or wherever you get your podcast